como ustedes pueden ver a mis espaldas
en este momento En este restaurante
argentino donde se han reunido alrededor
de 500 hinchas pese a los bajísimas
temperaturas menos cero y una lluvia que
no ha parado se vive un ambiente de
fiesta como ustedes pueden ver desde ese
partido tan emocionante tan lleno de
niveles bajos altos que no apto para
cardíacos Como dirían algunos estuvo muy
movido y los argentinos no dejaron en un
solo momento de cantar y de apoyar a su
selección que sea Coronado campeona
después de 36 años Yo diría que una vez
diente un hecho adicional da esa fiesta
sería que Messi ha subido al pedestal de
los más grandes de la historia con
Maradona y con Pelé justamente me
acompaña a esta hora Andy ella ha estado
aquí desde horas muy tempranas Andy Cómo
viviste todo ese partido bueno fue muy
emocionante
pero la verdad que creo que es lo que
Messi se merecía después de tantos años
finalmente poder levantar la copa y en
un partido donde fue estaban
protagonistas Así que toda alegría Hoy
somos todos argentinos yo creo que ha
hecho más especial esta celebración el
hecho de que Messi el más grande de la
historia por fin haya levantado como lo
vimos hace unos instantes la Copa del
Mundo crees tú eso cómo lo vives tú como
Argentina yo creo que Messi es sin duda
es el más grande de la historia y hoy es
simplemente una demostración de lo que
todos sabíamos pero hoy puede decir con
confianza si es el más grande de la
historia y le dio una Argentina a
millones y millones una alegría millones
y millones de argentinos Así que hoy es
su día hoy se consagró para siempre sin
duda se consagró Cuál ha sido o cuál fue
el gol más emocionante de este
campeonato que para ti por supuesto yo
creo que el primer que metió hoy hoy fue
como darnos ese empujón de decir vamos
si se puede es eso Messi agarra la
pelota y Argentina se emociona es como
si se puede
[Música]
como ustedes pueden ver entonces la
fiesta Aquí se va a prolongar hasta
altísimas horas de la noche y por
supuesto como ustedes pueden ver
muchísimo ambiente de celebración y
sobre todo ese elemento adicional Messi
se ha consagrado hoy como el más grande
de la historia ustedes que son unos
expertos en deportes tiene muchísima más
detalles de toda esa carrera excepcional
que ha tenido Messi pero lo cierto Es
que hoy en las emociones de los hinchas
argentinos pudimos ver que por fin se
cumplió ese sueño de Ver a Messi campeón
de la copa del mundo y hoy el Sunday
telegraph ustedes lo recordarán que fue
el capitán de la selección inglesa
escribió una columna como uno de los
rivales de Messi en distintos partidos
por muchos años y dijo que Messi Es
simplemente más grande de la historia
que no hay ninguno como él y que lo
enfrentó en repetidas oportunidades y
que Recuerda que es pequeñito de Tamayo
pero gigante en Talento y que recuerdo
además que Messi nunca en la cancha en
una sola palabra todo lo hacía su juego
él es el festejo a esta hora aquí en
Londres
le pregunto Luisa Cuál ha sido la
reacción si es que ha podido pulsarla de
los fanáticos ingleses porque Inglaterra
cayó eliminado frente a Francia me
imagino que había digamos alguna
animadversión por ese hecho sí se han
sumado ingleses a esta celebración
[Música]
sí había aquí algunos hinchas ingleses
que estaban por supuesto a favor de la
Argentina como lo mencionas después de
que Francia eliminó hace casi una semana
a Inglaterra del mundial entonces
preferían obviamente apoyar a Argentina
en esta final y lo cierto Es que ha
habido como sabemos desde hace
muchísimos años un tipo de tensión entre
los hinchas ingleses y los hinchas
franceses Así que la Argentina fue la
mejor oportunidad para sacar revancha en
esta copa del mundo pero como lo dije en
ese momento hablando con los hinchas
ingleses ellos esperan que más adelante
en el próximo mundial puedan tener
revancha pero hoy han estado apoyando a
la Argentina